abdal ténor montrent un genou gardois ah
ben je vais pas trop bruit il est 5h30 9
du match hormis je suis à londres pour
ford ford qui m'a invité pour aller
découvrir sa nouvelle voiture électrique
qu'il en soit europe c'est la ford
mustang maquis du coup je suis au
langham hôtels dans l'ombre arrivé hier
repartir assez incroyable en fait son
affaire c'est que aujourd'hui va
remonter le cours du temps on va se
refaire la journée mais juste avant
incroyable j'en ai fait des chambres
d'hôtel je vais emmener visiter à chaque
fois mais là on est quand même dans un
ebook est super et libre regardez la
viole le truc c'est gigantissime le truc
est juste énorme
regardez ça amène des finitions les
pentes détail jusqu'à venir vous changez
vous branchez vous avez pour tout le
monde
le truc que votre plus du bois je crois
que c'est la salle de bain je veux pas
dire mais d'un bout à l'autre on va se
perdre à sa carrière avec une énorme
baignoire une énorme douche mais surtout
la taille du truc
et attendez c'est pas fini et là vous
avez bien évidemment le dressing avec
elle et peignoirs tout ce qu'il faut on
est donc sur une journée où on va parler
d'automobiles honda espère autour de la
toute nouvelle ford mustang mac
[Musique]
fetisov s'écoule en fait ça commence par
là en fait ça a commencé un petit peu
plus tôt lorsqu'on quitte l'avion du
retour de san francisco à paris un
[Musique]
ennemi toi dans les deux sens qu'à 5h
demain
comme vous n'êtes pas très gentils avec
moi
mignon ici mais c'est là qu'on aurait dû
être belle c'est là qu'on sera la
prochaine
mais c'est vachement bien ici a bien
dormi ça va mal et cela s'applique pas
mais bon les yeux là voilà là comme
thébaux bon là on vient de se faire onze
heures d'avion autour de san francisco
mois jean charest a que dans deux heures
vous emmène à londres on va aller voir
les nouveautés du côté de chez ford et
de l'électrique
l'automobile voilà comme quoi il n'ya
pas que du smartphone y aussi punch aux
différentes à voir
[Musique]
il ya donc eu un voyage san francisco
paris paris/londres arrivée à londres
par découvert un nouveau batteur
électrique ford la ford mustang naquit
alors on a vraiment l'idée globale de la
ford mustang et la voiture d'exception
là on est dans la continuité de
l'histoire mais aussi dans une toute
nouvelle histoire parce qu'on va vous
trouver les codes de la mustang telle
qu'on la connaît mais c'est quand même
tout autre chose à 7
[Musique]
les commandants
votre domaine là juste devant la cnac
devant l'événement ford revient de faire
un tournoi de la nouvelle ford mustang
électrique est assez incroyable en fait
sensation surtout parce qu'au match
n'est pas spécial de l'automobile donc
pas moi qui vais peut-être vous le
décret de la meilleure façon
mais le vécu en fin de partie mais en
terme de sensations au touquet juste
absolument incroyable c'est extrêmement
soustrait très science où ça c'est un
peu la base de l'électrique
[Musique]
retenez
armin veh ballack va se garder les
finitions intérieures là vous avez toute
la recharge sans fil pour poser vos
smartphones que vous voulez pour les
porte gobelets bien évidemment un as du
sbc on l usb un peu plus standard ya
tout ce qu'il faut pour venir recharger
donc on est vraiment sur la voiture
était que la collectivité
on la revoit vraiment vraiment là-dessus
on a des enceintes bang & olufsen là les
finitions avec les surpiqûres comme ça
sont vraiment vraiment vraiment top
regarder l'écran à l'intérieur pour le
contrôle c'est juste hallucinant radio
montréal yvan téléphone on peut tous
venir piloter ou quasiment tous c'est
pas mal ce tableau de bord complet c'est
un peu bizarre en fait parce que vous
avez effectivement quelque chose qui est
dans ses poches de grosse tablette avec
juste une molette physique et vous avez
ensuite là bas on le voit le petit
tableau de bord avec vos km/heure à 6 et
des miles par heure parce que forcément
on est en angleterre sur le lancement
mais sinon vous aurez vous des
kilomètres ainsi il a beaucoup mûri il
ya beaucoup de monde derrière moi vous
avez la nouvelle forme du stand maquis
ford arrive dans l'électrique et avec
pas n'importe quel vécu avec une voiture
de légende de l'électrique
c'est la forme du sang de l'apprendre 80
je sais pas si vous connaissez sûrement
pas mais c'est juste une des voitures
légendaires tous les gars ont pâti des
petits et même surtout quand ils sont
grands maintenant rêver d'avoir il rêve
d'avoir une ford mustang moi c'est mon
cas j'aurais beau n'avoir eu ce niveau
tel salaire vraiment canon c'est très
chouette que franck soit arrivé là
dessus il ya pas mal de configuration il
ya pas mal de choses à faire
du point de vue de puissance c'est une
bague à colbert opus commander sur
internet
vous collectez rallye pour commander
votre ford mustang maquis bon bah
pourquoi pas on voit qu'une toute façon
c'est logique que les marques viennent à
se mettre à l'électrique
on a un changement des deux côtés de
l'automobile tout le monde sinon ford
arrive directement avec un modèle comme
ça qui est dans le but d'appuyer vous
tester c'est un prototype donc il ya
certaines choses sont pas complètement
définitive dont on va voir au niveau du
logiciel dans toute l expérience globale
est vraiment moche mais le produit
vraiment intéressant rien que pour ça
repousse bleu provence
[Musique]
si vous êtes amoureux des anciennes ford
mustang de ce qu'est la mustang
classique
c'est sûr que là dessus vous risquez est
un petit peu déroutés ou dans ok je
retrouve pas les codes de la mustang ont
les dents tout autre chose on est dans
de la voiture électrique alors forte
garde effectivement la marque mustang
une marque extrêmement forte mais qui
pour le coup là dessus et quand même
relativement différente pour ça c'est la
ford mustang mckee mc i électrique voilà
c'est une nouvelle histoire ça raconte
vraiment autre chose s'il faut savoir
que depuis 2010 8 ford a dépensé pas
moins de 11 millions d'euros pour
l'électrification de ces voitures est là
avec cette nouvelle mustang acquis au
nez sur le premier véhicule 100 %
électrique fabriquée par ford l'idée là
dessus c'est effectivement le design la
performance le côté voitures de légende
avec la ford mustang
bien évidemment la collectivité c'est ce
qui nous amène aujourd'hui parce que si
vous venez chercher une expertise
automobile où vous souhaite un petit peu
déçu moi c'est vraiment les expertises
tech
parce que cette voiture effectivement
elle est bourrée de technologie apple
chose intéressante mais surtout du tout
qui - vraiment m'intéresser c'est le
côté connectivité votre smartphone la
tablette à l'intérieur qui fait vraiment
de belles promesses
j'imagine que si vous êtes un fan de
formule ce temps vous arrivez vous dit
c'est quoi cette mas qui j'ai déjà vu
les premiers retours sur instagram sur
twitter d'ailleurs ce comité à me suivre
ce n'est pas déjà le cas il ya peut être
parce qu'ils sont assez critiques parce
que je pense que s'ils retrouvent pas
effectivement par rapport aux codes
d'une mustang un peu standard on est
vraiment sur autre chose il faut
vraiment imaginé l'histoire différemment
alors effectivement on retrouve les
codes esthétiques les bandes au niveau
des phares à l'arrière et pas mal de
code qui sont là on reste sur une ford
mustang c'est une toute nouvelle
histoire que vous nous racontez fort là
dessus et ce qui est assez drôle c'est
qu'en fait cette formule temps si vous
êtes dedans fièrement le ressenti que
j'ai eu cette formule sans qu elle fait
absolument pas de bruit seul et c'est
assez marrant parce quand on monte dans
une voiture comme sa forme le second dit
s'attendre entre qui ronronne alors je
sais sont électriques je sais que c'est
la ford mustang maquis qu'elle est pas
là pour faire du bruit
est ce un peu déroutant et justement il
ya un talkie vachement intéressant c'est
que ford travaille là-dessus à se dire
on doit rajouter du bruit déjà une passe
qu'une question de réglementation
une voiture électrique aujourd'hui eh
bien elle fait pas de bruit ça peut être
dangereux une voiture doit faire du
bruit de pouvoir être captées par les
piétons
nick mois pour les questions de
réglementation et de sécurité et en plus
de ça il vous reste donc
oui extérieur et du bruit intérieur si
vous souhaitez je pense que pour le
bruit à l'intérieur pour vous retrouviez
le bruit que peuvent faire en tout cas
une forme mustang
donc on vient rajouter un petit hack
pour ajouter un côté un peu fake mais
rajouter à l'expérience ça effectivement
c'est à voir si j'ai la possibilité
l'attesté derrière moi je vous dirai ce
que j'en pense l'objectif lettres sur
moi c'est toucher une nouvelle frange de
population population un peu plus jeunes
on m'annonce les millénium alors je dis
ok les mellino je suis d'accord mais sur
une voiture qui coûte quand même 48000
euros d'entrée c'est quand même
relativement élevé par contre je
comprends vraiment effectivement le dis
de se dire ok on veut toucher une frange
de population qui a les moyens qui veut
s'offrir cette voiture là qui aiment
l'idée de la ford mustang d'arriver sur
l'électrique avec la ford mustang maquis
l'idée en gros derrière silhouette à
venir un peu de dynamiser la marque
on m'annonce une autonomie jusqu'à 600
km il ya deux types de batteries qui
permettront d'aller plus ou moins loin
mais surtout ce qui est très
impressionnant ça j'ai pu tester déjà
dans la voiture on s'est fait un grand
coup d'accélération sa part extrêmement
vite et si vous partez sur le modèle gt
il ya vingt simulateur le truc ça vous
jette littéralement contre les murs
alors pas vous ne devez pas la voiture
balai dans le mur ce n'est pas ça mais
en fait une accélération qui est
vraiment hypra impressionnante vous avez
un 0 à 100 en moins de 5 secondes et
surtout la sensation à l'accélération
c'est extrêmement coupé sa part très
vite et ça avec l'électrique c'est
vraiment hyper impressionnant
on a trois modes de conduite en gelée
j'ai pris mes notes c'est un gage wastl
m.brahim voilà moi je ne peu à peu comme
ça ça une fois de plus c'est une voiture
à venir essayer bien tc pouvoir se
rendre compte
en gros je pense que vous avez à côte un
peu plus soft où on va venir piloter à
conduire d'un côté voilà un peu plus
soft urbain et à côté un peu plus de +
sport ou là par contre effectivement
vous appuyez petit vous partez par
contre on habite l'autonomie est ce que
vraiment de diminuer très rapidement là
dessus la voiture à l'extérieur je la
trouve plutôt bien réussi on a vraiment
les codes qu'on a sur une ford mustang
un peu plus traditionnel jeu des
guillemets parce que j'aime me faire
engueuler par les puristes mais c'est un
peu l'idée en tout cas qui est bien
c'est de voir effectivement l'automobile
qui va chercher à plus de connectivité
compatible ios mais également android on
peut venir
branchez votre smartphone revivre
smartphone directement à votre voiture
et surtout vous avez un nouveau système
multimédia qui s'appelle 5 alors cinq
jeux les vues vite fait je n'ai pas pu
vraiment le tester mais en tout cas je
trouve ça intéressant surtout ce qui
m'intéresse si vous voulez avec les
les voitures aujourd'hui c'est de se
dire comment est ce qu'on arrive à faire
un lien entre les objets qu'on a avec
nous en permanence notamment que sont
vos smartphones est ce que vous arrivez
dans votre voiture parce que l'idée
globale derrière tout ça c'est une
transparence totale
vous partez de chez vous et vos
smartphones ou piloter votre maison vous
arrivez dans votre voiture elle est
connectée toujours de la même manière
avec le même écosystème orvault email
sur votre table de leur combi conduit
c'est extrêmement dangereux vous le
faites pas mais l'idée effectivement de
pouvoir avoir vos emails comme ça de
pouvoir accès à un côté peut-être un peu
plus l'écart tissement ludique pour le
passager uniquement bien évidemment
pouvoir avoir vos appels vos essais
restent en mains libres bien évidemment
et en plus de tout ce qui est cool c'est
derrière ils nous ont mis de
l'intelligence artificielle qui va venir
en gros à prendre vos usages et
paramétrer votre voiture pour tout ce
que vous avez l'habitude de faire alors
lorsque vous prenez la voiture voulu
laisser quinze jours donc elles
apprennent un peu à vous connaître
c'est comme une rencontre amoureuse 1 il
faut un petit peu de temps pour réussir
à se connaître et ensuite elle arrivera
à connaître vos préférences en termes de
musique en termes de température et vous
entrerez en découlent et son traitement
optimal lorsque vous rentrez dans votre
forme mustang maquis c'est une voiture
qui sera disponible la livraison à
partir de novembre 2020 faut pas être
trop pressé et qui en commande en ligne
dès maintenant
bien évidemment cette voiture à
l'électrique il faut la recharger vous
en douterez vous avez plusieurs
possibilités lui il faut effectivement
je pense avoir une maison pour prévenir
la branche et c'est un appartement sa
part forcément extrêmement simple vous
pouvez les recharger directement sur
votre prise domestique mais ça va être
un peu plus de temps si vous voulez que
ça y est beaucoup plus vite
il propose qu'ils appellent une onebox
qui apparaîtra de la recharge est
extrêmement rapidement la problématique
de l'éthique aujourd'hui effectivement
de se dire il faut qu'il déborde un peu
partout pour qu'on puisse la branche et
la recharger parce que sinon vous
risquez globalement de vous embêter
l'idée c'est de se dire ok je pars en
vacances ou est-ce qu'il faut que je
puisse me posais me recharger combien de
temps que j'ai devant moi
est ce que je risque pas de tomber en
panne est vraiment toute cette question
globale qui à prendre en considération
bien évidemment ford nous annonce
déploiement des bornes de recharge
aujourd'hui un apôtre des bulls en
électrique on va vraiment sur
l'électrification globale au niveau de
différentes marques ya beaucoup de
marques traction électrique pourrait
effectivement faire de lens tesla qui
est extrêmement présent il ya beaucoup
de matches beaucoup de premium que ta
force quelle manière on peut retrouver
des bornes d'un peu partout pour charges
extrêmement rapidement parce que ça
reste quand même la caisse voûte de
cette histoire pas vous donner mon
retour sur le côté multimédia tablette 5
tu peux pas vous le dire aujourd'hui en
tout cas c'est très alléchante où la
voiture vraiment alléchant je trouve
intéressant la trouve assez sexy une
fois de plus on n'est pas sur l'idée de
la mustang standards qu'on avait au
début on regarde les codes me raconte
vraiment toute nouvelle histoire
moi je trouve ça plutôt cool
au metteur j'espère pouvoir la tester
ultérieurement et vous dire réellement
ce que j'en pense c'est comment je
trouve tout le système multimédia
intérieur et qu'est-ce qu'on peut
réellement parce que c'est vraiment ça
l'intérêt sur les usages derrière mais
sur le principe je trouve ça plutôt bien
à vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire comment vous la
trouvez cette ford mustang maquis bien
pas bien intéressante sexy pas sexy
d'employés du design produit global est
ce que vous pourriez vous laisser tenter
est ce qu'au contraire vous dit non on
est pas sur l'idée de la mustang
standard mais surtout moins ça me plaît
pas ça m'intéresse pas dites moi tout ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
et est ce que voulait continuer à parler
d'automobiles est ce que ça vous botte
on a eu à découvrir un peu les nouveaux
modèles liés à la tek tek et automobiles
aujourd'hui ça ne fait plus qu'un une
sacrée belle histoire à raconter
donc dites moi tout ça en bas en
commentaire et quant à nous on se
retrouve demain pour continuer à parler
de tech nous embrasse à demain tiens
[Musique]
c
c'est bon tu des abonnés
[Musique]